present the Award for Best Actor in a
leading role here is a singer actress
who was a songwriting nominee for nine
to five in a former nominee for leading
actor as well as for the writing of the
film rocky Dolly Parton and Sylvester
Stallone
nocturnal eating roll those words only
begin to describe the range and the
depth of performances nominated this
year and the nominees are for his role
as a university professor who meets the
teaching challenge of a lifetime and
educating Rita Michael King
for his portrayal of a poet with a good
deal more than poetry on his mind in
Reuben Reuben Tom Conte and in the title
role of a man dedicated to keeping the
traditions of British theatre alive in
the dresser
Tom Courtney
as the country singer who finds new
songs to sing and new people to love
when this when his life takes a turn for
the better and I know in depending
you'll see your cousin Robert Duvall and
as the roaring eccentric sir who needs
his troupe of Shakespearean actors
around more time England in the dress or
Albert Finney
and the winner is ha ha
thank you very much and very excited
very happy very moved very everything
tonight to be up here to be singled out
among from among all these very talented
people I sometimes come to the Academy
Awards and watch them year after year
and I get caught up in the spectacle of
it in the event in the very complex type
of entertainment and I guess I know I
forget that what we're really here for
is to single out who we think is the
best for that given year and if that's
what I am to be this year then I
appreciate it with I accept it with an
honor and and I'm very moved because of
that I think we set out to make make a
film a very truthful film a very good
film I think Bruce Beresford horton
Foote the hobo zmi should all be
commended very wonderful job that they
did in putting this film together I
think it's a valid film valid enough
that we have gotten very much applause
of a certain kind from certain members
of the country-western community such as
my friend Johnny Cash Willie Nelson
Waylon Jennings and this is certainly a
very high level of criticism coming from
those people and if I didn't have that
on one hand I would feel that this on
the other hand was not complete but the
combination of both tonight makes as it
makes this a very complete and exciting
evening for me tonight
and I want to thank the Academy very
much for this award I'm very happy thank
you